- Polizeirevier Ost, Brunner hier.
Ah, hallo, Lisa. Wie geht’s dir?
Was ist los? Geht es Emma nicht gut?
- Eh, doch, keine Sorge! Emma geht es gut.
Aber Nico hat ein Problem.
Er war auch am Flughafen.
Er kommt aus Spanien.
Ja, genau. Er kommt aus Spanien
und er hat ein Problem.
Seine Tasche ist weg
und er spricht nicht gut Deutsch.
- Hat er Papiere?
Einen Ausweis oder einen Pass?
- Hast du einen Pass? Passport?
Nein. Nicos Pass ist in seiner Tasche.
Aber er hat ein Foto von seiner Tante.
Sie wohnt auch hier in Deutschland,
aber Nico hat die Adresse nicht.
- Meine Tante … she has a bicycle shop.
- Seine Tante hat ein Geschäft,
ein Fahrradgeschäft.
- Wir suchen also eine Adresse.
Die Frau hat ein Fahrradgeschäft. Richtig?
Okay. Dann komm doch mit Nico zur Polizei.
- Danke, Papa!
- Gerne. Bis später.
- Bis später!
Vielleicht kann mein Vater uns helfen.
Er hilft. He helps.
- Super!
- Danke!
- Mach’s gut, Lisa. Tschau, Emma.
- Tschüss, Max!
- Tschau, Nico. Viel Erfolg!